emotional insecurity is the biggest
mental cancer in the world and it is
shockingly easy to fix it is called
putting it out there for some of you
that may be you're finally ready to
actually just do therapy and the safest
thing for you is saying out loud what
you feel about your mom or your dad or
your husband or your wife or your kids
that you're embarrassed or scared to say
to anybody else and in the closed room
of a therapy to a stranger for today
it's the safest place for others you
might go radical and say [__] it I'm
gonna do what garyvee just said on stage
and I'm going to literally post it
everywhere and there will be a lot of
pain with that there'll be collateral
damage but you're ready for others
you'll find a different way whether it's
meditation or exercise or eating
differently or journaling or a million
other things that you've heard a million
times but the reason you're not getting
what you want from it is you're not
being truthful with it you're protecting
yourself from yourself yet you're
tricking no one